hey John could totally use your help
right now I already assumed position you
can even like fix the camera for me a
little bit well it's totally cutting off
my head when I sit up straight just feel
like we don't belong in the same shop
hello guys I'm dragging Greg Alba
hi I'm monads not Greg exactly Monette
is a pleasant woman who loves to do yoga
so today we are sitting and uh and uh
mines Lotus what the hell am i doing
yours is almost Lotus that's crisscross
out that's the exact name for it okay
warm-up video try not to laugh or grin
vine Edition I rarely do these I rarely
do them but my net was complaining about
how she feels like she has a kind of
weird laugh so I figured if she feels
that weird about her laughing casual
conversation what if she can't control
her laugh and has to burst out huh what
would that sound like scary let's do
this okay these these can either be
really entertaining or super [ __ ]
boring wait you're already losing a bit
okay you can't laugh or grin it has to
be a straight face trust me I'm gonna
have a hard time too
okay I'm already feeling like oh [ __ ] no
whoa oh here it is
it's really hot that fan stopped working
oh okay no I'm not hell yeah dog let's
film this phone ad are you ready to not
laughing
Ren ah I'm ready
[ __ ] what are you gonna be this year sir
I really don't mind up with this so I
got something a hole that screamer
let's see it look though no thanks jeez
man it's all in your head no no no he
needs to know okay he's always clear oh
my father were drawing a little a story
we come on overhead lights
hums Christmas I know let me eat it up
go down you go let me [ __ ] you give me a
boy's name that starts with the letter H
she had something he hey yeah he had to
do first
yeah that is not what the [ __ ] is this
you go 80 miles per hour how long does
it take you to go 80 miles Oh help I
fall and I can't get up hey guys I'm
here with my boyfriend today is for fame
happy birthday mommy over hey guys hang
out with me
oh yeah what the [ __ ] is this boy that
escalated quickly I mean that really got
out of hand fast using yawning huh oh no
I would say [ __ ] hear me
thank you
hey what is up with these [ __ ] follow
these dads what is that
what [ __ ] we met pac-man we don't chase
that's what we don't chase that well I'm
out man humming strip [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you you cool [ __ ] you up
Oh yogurt twice
yeah this is so [ __ ] up to you snap it
up
mom sit down you don't smoke Larry
now you smoke it up no but I mean smoker
[ __ ] sometimes sometimes I do once in
a while you smoke meat now never
that was a lot that was a lot those lots
of process this video is gonna be really
difficult to discuss in any way possible
but we're gonna give it a shot
well we lost we we definitely lost did
you feel like laughing most of the
signposts there were times I was pretty
bored
yeah me too it's funny because I just
pictured the person making it laughing
hysterically while making it and that's
what made me laugh some of the clips not
so much some of the clips were just like
painful to watch they were super awkward
and also what I really liked that one
though with the kid crying and then it
was because of the body I thought like
this as funny as his kids crying yeah
but turned out to be not so that that
was clever that was a clever one there
you wonder you know what we're gonna
create a vine right now okay alright
John do you wish you get in on this vine
yeah I'm watching it behind the scenes
of the vine of whatever we're about to
film
does anyone have an idea does anyone
have an idea try not to laugh no we're
doing a vine Oh what about I don't know
just something we just saw a bunch of
vines okay uh what do we do
she's something fast-paced that doesn't
make a whole lot of sense really have
six most vine super still coming over
the buck
that's a rat in this story okay okay
okay okay all right not right right
anymore
glad that you thought of this um usually
I'm so quick - come on baby
um I think it's because the camera is
watching you come up with it it's like
it's that much more different yeah cuz
usually you can like pace around the
room and like you know scan usually you
yeah
maybe we should make a vine about not
being able to come up with a fine okay
you know what
it's because the cameras uh what do you
mean there's only six seconds ah we only
have fun gonna do it laughing we only
got six seconds all right let's give me
okay here we go I got this I got this
everything you looked
oh okay nice realize how stupid this
vine wait we can say what do you mean
there's only six seconds that's way
better
what do you mean there's only six
seconds oh we only have didn't take I
just say footage from all is compiled
into six like uh um way what sentence
again [ __ ] gonna do a laughing we only
got six seconds alright what do we mean
mmm
order what do we say in six we finally
got that vine down you can go to our
real rejects or mate white no the Greg
Alba fine featuring this lovely lady
nothing it's a new name not great at not
Greg yeah Jake everything well guys
listen um if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe today and become a
reject and Monnet has a channel two
called sweet eats I do and it is a very
pretty channel with pretty women on
there and occasionally a pretty guy I
was kind of pretty true he's pretty he's
pretty yeah I didn't see the other girl
you guys had she's beautiful I bet she
was I bet she was that channel has a lot
of beauty Gayle you are welcome we make
food we make healthy desserts and
breakfast and snacks and it's fun and
there's beauty there wonderful Instagram
Twitter follow us there you know